as we noted yesterday american taxpayers
pay a fortune for the money no object
intelligence community
and what do they get for that money well
the very pinnacle of the intelligence
community the director of national
intelligence avril haynes has just
released a report on quote
the hiring and retention of minorities
women and persons with disabilities
in the united states intelligence
community i know diversity is my
priority
when you're putting together a team to
go into raqqa and figure out where al
baghdad
is lurking and that certainly looks like
one diverse team they have over in
america's intelligence community alas
as the less craven media quickly figured
out that is not in fact
the cia's elite diverse wet work unit
but a stock photo you can download for
free
from shutterstock with the title
portrait of multicultural
office staff standing in lobby
unfortunately that picture wasn't
sufficiently diverse for the director of
national intelligence
because the report is also supposed to
be about persons with disabilities so
the world's most
lavishly funded intelligence community
found a couple of other
stock pictures of a lady in a wheelchair
and a blind guy with a dog
and photoshopped them onto the wings of
the group not terribly well if you zoom
in
to the bottom right hand corner you'll
see the blind guy's feet are casting a
shadow but the lady's feet behind
aunt but that's because the guy is
actually walking down the champs-elysees
to buy a cafe au lait and a piano
chocolate in 1997
and the gal in the wheelchair is at a
garden party in new zealand with
princess margaret in 1978 however
the photoshop experts of the
intelligence community did change the
color of the guy's suit
to fit in with the intelligence
community dress code
this is exactly the sort of attention to
detail
i would want if they were sticking me in
a full speed and putting me
undercover in a souk in jalalabad
what i don't understand is why they
didn't just photoshop into the
shutterstock
generic diversity pick trump's director
of national intelligence rick grinnell
who was an actual
authentic intelligence community gay
but according to the left seriously he
doesn't count as gay
because he wasn't confirmed by the
senate got that
america is now so thoroughly
credentialized
that you can be a practicing homosexual
and it doesn't count
unless your homosexuality has been
confirmed by
the senate does that need the filibuster
or is it just a straight up and down
you know what's always the depressing
thing for me about these diversity
reports muslims transgenders whatever
but where
are the canadians in the supposedly
diverse u.s
intelligence community oh no wait we've
just got the new edition
and lookie there in the back row oh
and there's my fellow torontonian debra
so she'll be right here in a moment
behind the guide dog oh and no wonder
tucker needed to get out ahead of that
nsa story
there he is me touring the gal at the
new zealand garden party in 1978.
does any hostile foreign power
need to be scared of a u.s intelligence
community lacking the photoshop skills
of your average middle schooler
or is that what they want the russians
to think
debra is the host of the dr debra so
podcast
and author of the trenchant and
insightful book that you should get the
end of gender all about
sex and identity uh deborah are you
quaking in front of the photo shopping
skills
of the us intelligence community
well thank you so much mark for having
me oh my god i love this
i have to say i thought this story was
absolutely hilarious
and i could have probably done a better
job of photoshopping on the original
photo
with a pair of scissors and a glue stick
so
absolutely regarding your regarding your
point about the director
actually on the dr debrasso podcast this
week
i talked to andrew sullivan who is a
conservative journalist who is also out
as gay
and we talked about how according to the
far left
gay men do not count as minorities
anymore because they're doing well in
society so it makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever but apparently that's the
logic
what i loved was this shutterstock
picture which it was
captioned group of multicultural
employees standing around in a lobby
and i can't believe this is the first
actual entity
to tell a minor employee go out and find
me a picture of
assorted uh multicultural minorities
standing around in a lobby in other
words
it's just cheap formulaic virtue
signaling
and the fact that it now extends up to
the deepest of the deep state
bureaucracy in the u.s just i think is
really testifies to how ridiculous this
whole thing is
yeah it's a little bit worrisome and i
do think that representation matters and
that people with disabilities deserve to
be
represented but i'm not sure that this
is the way to go about doing it
and i would also think that an
intelligence
agency would be more focused on the
security of the nation as opposed to
diversity mandates but maybe that just
makes me a little bit old-fashioned
it probably does deborah and i agree
with you but
on representation of minorities but the
idea that you just go and pick a stock
picture and say okay that's our minority
quotient
thank you so much deborah and uh
deborah's excellent
podcast is called the dr deborah so
podcast
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else